في الاثناء افادت مصادر دبلوماسيه للجزيره
بتاجيل التصويت لليوم الخميس على مشروع
قرار في مجلس الامن لتوسيع نطاق المساعدات
لغزه وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن ان الولايات المتحده تواصل لانخراط
بشكل مكثف وبناء مع عدد من الدول لمحاوله
حل بعض القضايا العالقه بشان قرار مجلس
الامن الخاص بغزه واضاف بلينكن في المؤتمر
الصحفي السنوي نهايه لنهايه العام ان
واشنطن تؤيد تسهيل وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى قطاع
غزه بالنسبه للتصويت في مجلس الامن نواصل
الانخراط بشكل واسع وبناه مع عدد من
البلدان لمحاوله حل بعض القضايا المعلقه
بشان قرار مجلس الامن لكن الغرض من القرار
كما ذكرت الدول التي طرحته هو تسهيل وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه والمساعده
على توسيع نطاقها ونحن نؤيد ذلك بالكامل
الولايات المتحده بذلت جهودا منذ اليوم
الاول كما اعتقد اكثر من اي دوله اخرى
للتاكد من امكانيه حدوث
ذلك